[Musica]
Devo essere onesto non non avevo idea di
come cominciare questo Ted X
o meglio avevo così tante idee che non
riuscivo a scegliere e quindi ho fatto
una cosa
che non si dovrebbe fare
Ho delegato questa scelta a una macchina
ho aperto il software che usiamo in
Oblique per generare testi e scrivere
articoli e gli ho chiesto tu Come
utilizzare come inizieresti un Ted che
parla di intelligenza artificiale e
intelligenza creativa
e la macchina mi ha generato in pochi
secondi Tra l'altro questa un po' di
possibilità e io ho scelto questa
La macchina dice aprirà il Ted chiedendo
al pubblico di immaginare un futuro in
cui tutti i nostri problemi attuali sono
stati risolti da macchine intelligenti
ci sta una macchina che ha enorme e
fiducia in se stessa e pensa che un
domani tutti i problemi di noi umani
saranno risolti da macchine intelligenti
però non mi sono fermato a questo io non
avevo bisogno solo di un testo Io ho
bisogno anche di immagini avevo bisogno
di immagini che mi accompagnassero in
questo racconto così ho preso un altro
software e gli ho detto Mi puoi generare
un po' di immagini di un piccolo
astronauta sulla luna
e sempre in pochi secondi la macchina mi
ha generato diverse immagini tra cui
questa e altre che vedremo lungo il
nostro racconto
Questo è quello che già oggi si può fare
con l'intelligenza artificiale applicata
alla creatività le macchine Oggi sono
già in grado di scrivere testi poesie
persino barzellette
sanno generare immagini
stanno comporre musica scrivere canzoni
e questo riguarda solo L'aspetto della
creatività più In generale come tutti
noi sappiamo
stiamo vivendo un'epoca di straordinaria
cambiamenti tecnologici un'epoca in cui
stiamo passando
dalla fantascienza con cui tutti noi
siamo cresciuti alla scienza fantastica
con cui tutti noi cresceremo stiamo
passando da questa idea di futuro qui
siamo giustamente un po' controluce
quindi non so se si vede e in più mi si
è anche spento il monitor comunque
questa idea di futuro che Ritorno al
futuro in cui il protagonista si trova
in una città del in cui i cani sono
portati in giro da guinzagli artificiali
a questa idea di presente un presente in
cui già oggi cani artificiali cani robot
girano per le strade Queste sono dei
robot della Boston Dynamic
ora se questa idea può magari spaventare
può far pensare a
futuri distopici alla Blade Runner
personalmente quella che la mia più
grande paura la mia più grande
preoccupazione non è che la macchina un
domani possa pensare come l'uomo ma che
l'uomo possa un domani pensare come una
macchina e quindi sostanzialmente smetta
di pensare
l'avvento dell'intelligenza artificiale
è una grandissima opportunità una
necessità per noi esseri umani di
investire su quello che è il nostro
tratto più distintivo Ovvero la
creatività e l'intelligenza creativa
Dunque oggi mi fa piacere condividere
con voi cinque parole
contro intuitive o per riprendere il
tema della giornata controluce che spero
possano aiutarci a sviluppare la nostra
creatività e la nostra intelligenza
creativa la prima parola è pazienza
le macchine non hanno Pazienza le
macchine sono state fatte e pensate
programmate per raggiungere un obiettivo
un risultato nel minor tempo possibile
noi umani non siamo delle macchine
Tuttavia talvolta abbiamo l'ambizione se
non la presunzione di pensare come delle
macchine
E quindi cosa Facciamo scegliamo un'idea
prendiamo una decisione non perché la
migliore ma perché la prima che ci viene
in mente perché non riusciamo a
sostenere quel sentimento di
inquietudine derivante dall'indecisione
perché E questo è uno dei grossi drammi
dell'epoca contemporanea noi non siamo
più in grado di stare da soli con i
nostri pensieri abbiamo bisogno di
occupare ogni singolo momento della
nostra vita per farvi capire il livello
drammatico che abbiamo raggiunto nel
2014 è uscita una ricerca su Science che
dimostrava come l'essere umano le
persone preferiscono ricevere dei
piccoli elettroshock al cervello
piuttosto che rimanere per un po' di
minuti da soli con i propri pensieri
le persone più Creative invece quelle
che hanno un'intelligenza creativa più
sviluppata sono quelle che riescono a
stare più a lungo quei problemi e quindi
alla fine arrivano a soluzioni più
originali
Einstein per esempio diceva Io non sono
particolarmente intelligente
semplicemente so stare più a lungo con
dei problemi e quindi arrivo a delle
soluzioni che possono sembrare più
intelligenti della stessa scuola della
stessa filosofia era John lease che è il
fondatore dei Monti Python su un attore
britannico che diceva Io non sono più
originale dei miei colleghi
Semplicemente sto più a lungo con le mie
idee penso ripenso le cambio finché non
arriva qualcosa di veramente originale
la terza parola seconda parola Scusate è
Resistenza
o meglio restrizioni Comunque anche la
resistenza fa parte del della creatività
restrizioni il software che che ha
generato il testo che vi ho fatto vedere
all'inizio è stato allenato con una
quantità di testi che un essere umano
anche se passasse tutta la vita a
leggere probabilmente non riuscirebbe a
raggiungere noi umani abbiamo dei limiti
e questo è estremamente positivo per la
creatività Perché i limiti stimolano la
creatività
qui Ho usato la parola restrizioni Ma
potevo usare
limiti appunto problemi errori
difficoltà crisi qualsiasi cosa che crei
un piccolo cortocircuito uno shock nella
nostra mente e ci allontani dalla nostra
routine quotidiana ci allontani da
quella che è una delle nemiche numero
uno della creatività che è la comfort
zone noi non nasciamo creativi noi
diventiamo creativi se non abbiamo
problemi da risolvere se abbiamo sempre
tutto quello che ci serve attorno a noi
se siamo sprofondando nella comfort zone
la creatività e l'innovazione è inutile
su questo un buon esempio ci arriva la
Samuel Beckett come sapete siamo il
Becket era irlandese Tuttavia e quindi
parlava inglese però i suoi più grandi
capolavori li ha scritti in francese non
perché fosse bilingue Anzi perché il
fatto di scrivere in una lingua diversa
dalla sua gli permetteva di essere più
creativo più asciutto ed effettivamente
diversi studi hanno dimostrato come
pensare scrivere
programmare progettare una lingua
diversa che dalla nostra ci aiuta a
superare a bypassare quegli automatismi
e quelle euristiche che ci abbiamo
naturalmente nel cervello e che non ci
permettono di essere creativi perché
perché ci fanno fare in automatico
sempre le stesse cose sempre nello
stesso modo
quindi qui il consiglio è cercate di
diversificare le attività che fate Se
siete un avvocato Provate a seguire un
corso d'arte assistete degli Artisti
Provate a seguire un corso di Finanza se
avete un budget da 100 mila euro provate
a pensare come se ne avesse 10.000
vedete cosa tirate fuori
la terza parola è disciplina qui il
nostro piccolo astronauta
girando sulla luna incontra un artista e
L'artista è da lì
quello che io trovo parentesi notevole
In queste immagine generata da un
software in pochi secondi intanto lo
sottolineo è che il software abbia preso
una decisione 100% algoritmica di
rappresentare la penso sia la terra in
lontananza il pianeta in lontananza Come
fosse una vignetta di Dalì Io penso che
un curatore potrebbe spenderci diverse
pagine su questa su questa scelta ma
cosa c'entra da lì o la rappresentazione
quantomeno di da lì con la disciplina da
lì c'entra con la disciplina perché da
lì Un giorno disse ho infranto il muro
dell'arte con disciplina da militare ed
effettivamente la disciplina è un
elemento essenziale della creatività
potremmo arrivare a dire che
più il lavoro che vogliamo fare è
indisciplinato più serve disciplina per
portarla a termine Diciamo che la
creatività è la somma di immaginazione
disciplina serve l'immaginazione serve
la curiosità serve dare spazio ai nostri
pensieri ma poi serve anche il rigore il
metodo della disciplina per farle
atterrare per selezionare l'idea su cui
investire e realizzarla
la quarta parola è concetto e qui il
nostro piccolo astronauta è stato
talmente coinvolto ispirato da da lì che
ha iniziato a dipingere ora la
creatività
non sta negli strumenti che utilizziamo
ma nel come li utilizziamo quindi non
sta nel cosa facciamo ma nel come lo
facciamo
noi potremmo avere anche la tecnologia
più all'avanguardia del mondo ma se la
Continuiamo a usare sempre nello stesso
modo se non la utilizziamo con una
mentalità creativa Allora è inutile
continueremo a fare sempre le stesse
cose dall'altra parte Einstein insegna
che ti basta una bussola per capire o
quantomeno intuire che lo spazio e il
tempo Sono relativi
voglio mostrarvi due dati
Il primo è questo il 77% è la
possibilità che un domani neanche tanto
remoto il lavoro dell'Imbianchino possa
essere automatizzato ovvero fatto da un
robot
adesso Vi mostro il secondo dato 16 per
cento
16% è la possibilità che il lavoro di un
pittore inteso come artista possa essere
fatto da un robot Se ci pensate il
pittore l'imbianchino utilizzano gli
stessi strumenti i pennelli e i colori
quello che fa veramente la differenza è
come li usano il concetto che c'è dietro
ed è questo il vantaggio di un artista o
il vantaggio di un essere umano sulla
macchina
tra i tanti lavori che ho fatto nella
mia vita c'è stato anche quello del
curatore d'arte e quando di fronte a
un'opera qualcuno diceva una frase che
avete detto ho sentito tutti voi a
questa potevo farlo anch'io
la mia risposta era Magari questa potevi
farla anche tu ma saresti stato in grado
di pensarla anche tu perché quello che
fa veramente la differenza
Io sono abbastanza sicuro che un domani
una macchina sarà in grado di generare
in pochi secondi centinaia di nuove
opere originali di Picasso
sono già stati fatti moltissimi
esperimenti in questa direzione Ma io
sono altrettanto sicuro che una macchina
non potrà mai vivere la vita di Picasso
e quindi vivere tutti i drammi tutti i
successi tutte le esperienze positive e
negative che Picasso ha vissuto e che
hanno portato all'ideazione la
realizzazione di quadri come Guernica
l'ultimo
l'ultima parola che volevo condividere
con voi forse la più importante di tutte
è senso critico
già oggi la nostra vita è scandita dal
algoritmi che influenzano le nostre
scelte
ogni volta che come esseri umani come
persone
decidiamo di delegare a una macchina la
fatica di pensare e di scegliere che sia
Come iniziare il Ted come ho fatto io
che sia quale film guardare e sia quale
prodotto comprare o peggio ancora
quali informazioni
leggere e quali informazioni ignorare in
questo momento Noi stiamo rinunciando a
quello che è uno dei nostri tratti più
distintivi che appunto il senso critico
stiamo lentamente diventando sempre meno
autonomi e sempre più autonomi
quindi il mio ultimo consiglio
è non fatelo mai non smettete mai di
pensare con la vostra testa e non con
quella di qualcun altro o peggio ancora
con quella di qualcos'altro Grazie
[Applauso]